you went camping not too long ago and
i'm curious because out here in la i
don't know how popular it is in the rest
of the country but there's a thing
called glamping where they you say
you're going camping but then people
find out that you're you're actually
kind of like staying in a nice cabin and
you're bringing a color television with
you and then they say you're not camping
you're glamping when you went camping
what was it oh it was camping we signed
up however for glamping oh um and that's
what you wanted we wanted glamping yeah
we got camping with critters and no
electricity
you know my my spouse is is a little
grand so we pull up to the campsite and
he's like is there where's the valet
there's no oh we're parking we're
parking ourselves really well we're
really camping but he thought that was
the extent of our campaign
your husband dwyane wade big nba star
and he's probably used to that kind of
service right he's used to he pulls up
you know and and people take care of him
and he's from the city he's from the
south side of chicago
there's uh yeah yeah he uh absolutely
does not want to be out in the
wilderness you know fitting for himself
by stretching right well we have a
picture here of you and dwayne and
i had to ask you you look very
comfortable those look like leather
butterfly chairs those look like chairs
that are made of beautiful leather are
they in fact they are in fact
who brings leather when they go camping
marshmallows uh bug repellent leather
chairs it all mm-hmm makes sense yeah
sure yeah what was uh was there a
special occasion when you guys went
glamping his uh duane's stylist callie
ann barnett she she got married and uh
had three nights worth of extravagant uh
parties and theme parties um uh up in
mendocino county and it was gorgeous and
amazing so it was three nights in the
woods yes okay
when you say three nights like what are
the fun things you can do in the woods
other than sit in a leather chair and
have a s'more what can you do in the
woods that's really
fun and fantastic well they had a
medieval time sort of like olympics
so there was you know um eating contests
and beer chugging contests and and uh
tug of war with the different guys oh
tug of world i mean i'm guessing you got
some professional athletes there
wouldn't they destroy a tug of war you
would think because that i put my money
on the nba guys no not at all and the
other team we just started calling them
grown man strength um and they murdered
them it wasn't even close who are the
other guys i'm just trying to like
father the of the bride like uncle tt
like wait a minute regular joe's regular
regular guys who's like yeah i'm a
substitute teacher in biology oh and uh
okay i'll take on the nba yank and they
won yes like fantastic not even close it
was amazing that's incredible it was
amazing maybe your guys weren't trying
that hard no no no no they'd been like
working at it there had been like some
training sessions beforehand
i mean this is this is the miami heat
they're used to winning and they yeah
not so much they got their asses kicked
by regular joes
very high centers of gravity yes that's
probably what it was the other guys are
probably low and sturdy yeah
little little fire plugs yeah yeah
these guys are like over six five they
tip over easy right
that's what i'm like my center of
gravity is right up here yeah you know i
have very long legs and then right here
is my center of gravity i'm just
constantly tipping for no reason
but saved by my hair